check this out
what you're seeing here is a bunch of
agents that have all never seen this
level before this level is in fact
procedurally generated and the agents
must somehow overcome the obstacles
right here you can see there's stumps
there's gaps the green one is performing
pretty well right here coincidentally
the green one is also what we're going
to look at in today's paper the idea
here is as i said these agents have
never seen these environments and the
environments are procedurally generated
every time i hit reset here a different
environment is created and also notably
on the right side right here i have
these sliders which with which i can
control the different properties of the
procedurally generated environments such
as how wide the gaps are how many steps
to the stairs there are and as i modify
these you can see the environments they
get more and more challenging as i slide
these things to the right hand side now
they get super challenging at some point
and the question is how do we train an
agent using reinforcement learning in
order to be able to solve these
challenging environments because it's
pretty clear that um if i want an agent
to solve an environment like this and it
remember it's a procedurally generated
environment so i can't just train it on
the same environment over and over and
over again until it gets it if i want to
train an agent to solve
the family of environments that are very
hard here it's almost impossible to do
so using from scratch reinforcement
learning because there's just never any
success uh of any of the agents like
they never finish an episode they never
get good reward they always stumble at
the first obstacle
and
so what's the what's the way we
i still want the green one to to
actually make this come on green one
come on
ah it's not gonna make it right
so the idea is that what we want to do
is we want to develop a curriculum so a
curriculum means that we're going to use
this ability to create levels of
different difficulties to
guide the agent to learn more uh
no
to learn more and more difficult
environments so we're going to start
with very easy environments very flat
environments not many gaps in them not
many stairs in them so fairly easy
environments like this and we use
reinforcement learning and try to teach
the agent just to solve this level now
most of them will do a fairly good job
at that level
as you can see not too much of a problem
some stumble some don't but you know
this is solvable and then we will
progressively as the agent gets better
and better increase the difficulties of
the level and
using that using that difficulty
increase over time there is a chance
that the agents they learn more and more
and more what it
in they learn more and more to
go and solve these levels so
from scratch learning of the difficult
environment environments might not be
possible however there is a chance if we
design a curriculum
in the correct sequence of difficulties
for the agents to learn this is not
unlike humans learn in
you may have heard of this uh
what you want to do is train in the zone
of proximal development or something
like this which which essentially means
that you want to
always challenge yourself just outside
of your current abilities and that's how
you maximize your progress in learning
that's the same idea that we have here
with these evolving curricula over time
so the paper we're going to look at is
called evolving curricula with regret
based environment design by jack parker
holder and minky jiang and others mainly
by meta ai but there's a bunch of
collaborations with ucl uc berkeley
university of oxford and yeah i guess
that's it
so this paper combines the
recent developments in regret based
algorithms that go about
making a curriculum and evolution which
is another way that people go about this
so the paper proposes to train a single
agent not a family of agents a single
agent that is generally capable of
solving all kinds of difficulties and
levels and to do that via an automated
curriculum that is given by a teacher
algorithm the teacher algorithm itself
is not learned the teacher algorithm is
actually defined by a
a like a this schematic right here and
all of this is regret based which makes
it independent of kind of domain
specific heuristics so the goal of this
algorithm right here is to have a
general algorithm to design these
curricula without being reliant on
essentially creating a new heuristics
for all of the
different tasks it needs to solve
so we're going to look at it here's a
brief overview over the algorithm itself
how does it do it how does it get an
agent to learn step by step and the most
difficult question is you know how fast
do you increase with the difficulties of
your levels because if you increase not
fast enough that you're essentially
stuck in learning if you increase the
difficulty too fast you have the same
problem again in that the agent will not
be capable of of keeping up
so what you want to do is you want to
have some sort of a level generator and
that is what we just saw before in in
this on web demo by the way you can go
look try out this web demo for yourself
at
axelagent.github.io i'll obviously i'll
link it in the description to this video
but you want to have some sort of a
level generator which is essentially the
thing that i have here on the right i
want to have the ability to create
different levels
this doesn't need to be parameterized
like it is here for example in this maze
worlds that they portray right here all
i have is an empty room and then i have
the ability to place blocks in it so
every pixel can either be a wall or not
a wall
and that's it that's a generator the
generator can just place blocks and and
that's it there's no need for
for some sort of a slider here that
controls the difficulty that's going to
be done completely automatically you'll
as you'll see
so
once we have the generator we could
already build some sort of an curriculum
algorithm right we could just sample
different levels from the generator and
then just train the agent on all of them
however that wouldn't amount to much of
a curriculum as it would probably
generate easy and hard levels all you
know throughout each other and the agent
would be able to solve the easy levels
maybe a little bit and then maybe a bit
of the harder levels but it's if you
don't sequence this correctly um there's
a there's a big chance that you're going
to fail
mostly because
[Music]
as the level design space gets higher
and higher uh most levels are either
going to fall in the too easy or way too
hard section and not a lot are going to
be in that zone of proximal development
and therefore you don't have much of a
learning signal so we need to somehow
filter and and and curate these levels
that we generate
so we have a generator and the generator
simply gives us the starting bunch of
levels and
i believe um
you can also go to the generator within
the algorithm and so on but imagine the
generator gives us just a bunch of
starting levels this is one of these
starting levels i'm going to take a
different color right here otherwise you
won't see that's even worse thank you
so the generator gives us a bunch of
starting levels and
these go to the student again the
student here that's a single agent there
is not a family of agents the
evolutionary methods here are not in
with regard to the student but to the
levels themselves so there's one student
that trains on all the different levels
so what we do is we simply evaluate we
ask we let the student run on this level
and we see how well it does and we're
going to measure its regret so the
regret of a student we're going to get
to that measure it's essentially an
estimate of how far the student is away
from the optimal policy on that
particular level and what we want to do
is we want to strictly select for levels
that have high regret
so levels where the student is far away
from the optimal policy because those
are the levels where the student can
still learn something
and if we do that correctly then this
automatically sequences this these
levels in the in the
in the sequence of difficulty such that
they're always just at the edge of what
the student can do
and you'll see how that works in a bit
so we want to measure their regret and
we have this we have the buffer right
here the buffer
is where all the levels that we
currently think are interesting to for
the student to learn at
reside
this buffer is managed by the curator
that the curator is essentially just
it's just a bucket of levels that
that we think are interesting
what we then do is we can replay those
levels so we can actually train the
student on the levels but we also if we
just train the students on these levels
that's not much of an interesting thing
so we also need a way to update that
buffer and the way we update the buffer
is we select some of the levels for
editing
so some of the levels we think okay
these are good levels but could we make
them like just a bit more difficult
because the student can solve them now
so what's a way to make them more
difficult then we send them through an
editor and the editor again this can be
pretty much anything so in our example
up here the editor could simply either
place another block right here or remove
a block what is important is that
different from the generator the
generator just generates a new thing
while the editor modifies the existing
things and the assumption is that
um if i modify something that has a
difficulty x right then if i modify it
to
x hat then the difficulty of x hat will
not be too much different
so what i'm going to do is i'm at let's
say here is the student's starting point
and the student increases its ability
round by round so maybe this is the zone
that the student can solve right now and
i select a level that is here so the
student can just about solve it and then
i modify that with the editor a little
bit and i maybe produce i produce
different offspring like here here here
and here so what i want to do is i want
to select for the offspring and here's
where that's where the evolutionary
method comes in i want to select for the
offspring that it will
will make progress for the student so
that the student just can't solve right
now and add that to the buffer of things
where i do reinforcement learning on so
with the editor i create a bunch of
different offspring for this level
as we see right here
and i evaluate the student on them i
measure the student's regret and if the
regret is high i put that back into the
buffer
so in this way i always keep the buffer
filled with levels that the student just
can't like it's just at the zone of
where the student can solve them so if i
now add the blue circled levels
obviously the next you know i'm going to
increase my ability to out here a little
bit in this direction right and then
maybe here is another level that i
modify with these two and that increases
the student's ability
to here
and then from these levels i will again
create offspring maybe to here and here
again i will filter out the ones that
become easier
and
so as you can see the students abilities
they will continually increase guided by
this metric of this regret so
that's the entire algorithm essentially
you'll have one student that is
generally capable and the buffer right
here
will always contain levels that the
student just can't can't or
just about can solve by measure of these
regret and continuously editing
obviously this doesn't work everywhere
like there needs there's a lot of
preconditions for this to work for
example you need to be able to have this
level generator and level editor
you need to be able to
create levels of various difficulties
not out of the box but it like should be
possible in principle there
there should be the possibility of
creating a curriculum in the first place
which is not possible for all the
tasks especially with the condition that
if i modify the problem a little bit
like this thing right here if i modify
the problem a little bit then the
the difficulty
should only
be modified by a little bit like that is
not a given for many many tasks however
if this is all given
then
it becomes suddenly possible
and of course we run into all the
problems of having a single student like
there's catastrophic forgetting and so
on but we don't we don't worry about
this right here uh as you might have
seen previously that the excel agent
right here this um
the green agent no matter kind of what
the terrain is its strategy is always
sort of the same so its strategy is
always to kind of hold one leg out and
bounce on the hind leg
and okay that that might not have been
um
so it will always
it's not gonna make that it always
bounce on the hind leg actually most of
them will do it bounce on the hind leg
and kind of wiggle the front leg and
that's how it bridges gaps and stairs
and ladders and so on okay most of them
do that but
you'll see that this is a problem of i
think having a single single agent solve
these things
if you want a single agent to be solved
to solve all the environments that means
that implicitly kind of one's one
strategy or one set of strategies must
be enough to solve all the environments
which is also not a given for much of
the
world of reinforcement learning however
this can all be fixed
so this was the overview now let's dive
into a little bit
more into the algorithm itself again we
have not yet
we there's still a crucial element and
that is this
regret that we haven't talked about yet
but the algorithm in code looks like
this um i want to
i want to initialize a policy that this
is the student policy pi
and this level buffer
so the buffer is uh is lambda i guess
lambda okay
so i'm going to sample some initial
levels and i'll just assume that the
initial levels here
they're they're going to be mixed in
difficulty so they're going to be some
some easy levels and some hard levels
and some levels that the student might
just be able to solve out of the box
or not
so well then we're going into a while
loop the big like while not converged
we're going to sample a replay decision
and the replay decision is essentially
it's a binary variable that tells me do
i want to uh take a level from the
buffer or do i want to take a level from
the a new level from the generator
because if you only have initial levels
in your buffer right then you're kind of
limited by the evolution of these levels
so much unlike we have non-convex
optimization problems in deep learning
these these
landscapes of levels might be super
duper non-convex
and
that's why if you just evolve a bunch of
levels there is obviously the danger
that you get that you sort of
narrow like you
you never
so if you if you go down upon if you
teach the agent to go like down a bunch
of stairs and and you go
ever more and more stairs more and more
stairs but the initial levels never had
like a big cliff like this uh your agent
will not be able to solve it even with
this method because no amount of adding
stair steps will get you to the big
cliff and that's why it's important to
every now and then actually sample a
level from the level generator
to bring some diversity in there because
that's what i see
with this method is probably pretty easy
to teach yourself into a corner
so if we have something from the level
generator
we collect the trajectory
and it's important that we have two
different modes right here we have the
student in evaluation mode so every time
that we have some level some new level
we first evaluate the student on it we
want to know whether the student can
actually solve it or not on how well it
can solve it
so what do we do
we compute the approximate regret we
don't actually train on this level we
just evaluate it and that is a property
i think that reduces the signal to noise
ratio tremendously we want to pre-filter
what levels we train on we don't just
want to train on all of them so this is
a this is interestingly enough a method
where
uh even though we have the training data
available it seems to be better if we
filter the training data it's still good
training data right any of these levels
is good training data for reinforcement
learning it's not like there's noisy
data or the label is wrong or something
but it seems to be quite important to
accurately select the levels we want to
train on so that is that is an
interesting thing by itself
but you what you'll see in this
algorithm is that they always will first
evaluate a level
determine whether the regret is high or
whether it is in the zone of proximal
development and only then use this that
level to actually train the agent on
that is interesting
so we compute this regret and we add the
level to the buffer so the level here is
this
theta so these are the parameters again
here that we evolve we evolve two sets
of parameters the parameters of
pi which is the students
policy but that is just a very simple
proximal policy optimization
reinforcement learning algorithm right
here we don't actually care what kind of
rl algorithm it is as long as it can
learn
the interesting parameters here are the
parameters of the levels and this could
be the level itself in case of this maze
or it could be the parameters
no actually it would be the level the
level itself
right it needs to be an actual
instantiation of the level not just the
parameters that you enter into the
generator unless
the generator is deterministic
and we only add it to the buffer if the
score meets a threshold so that is where
we filter out things where
the regret is either
where the regret is too low
so only if
it is a hard level for the student to
solve we
put it into the buffer and we'll get to
how we actually filter out the levels
that are too hard in a second
so that's just if we decide we need a
new level if we decide actually that we
want to go into the the buffer we're
going to sample a level that we've
previously added into the buffer and
remember we've determined that all of
these are in the zone of proximal
development we train we collect the
policy and we actually train so this is
where we train we train on a level that
we sampled from the buffer in the first
place it's the only time we train the
agent at all
and then we are not done with this level
yet
what we do is we take the same level
that we just sampled and we actually
edit it so here edit to produce
theta prime
and the editing can be as i said
anything as long as you can reasonably
assume that any edit
will not distort the difficulty too much
right so it needs to distort the
difficulty somewhat but not too much
again we collect the trajectory we do
not train it we do not we simply run the
student on the new levels exact same way
we did before we compute the regret and
we add it to the buffer if the score
meets a threshold optionally update the
editor using the score so that that can
be
the the editor itself could be some sort
of dynamic algorithm or not
so that is the algorithm in a nutshell
it's pretty simple there is a buffer i
train on levels inside the buffer and
only on levels that are inside the
buffer how do levels get into the buffer
two ways
they can be
sampled either from the level generator
or they can be edited from levels that
are already in the buffer however both
of them will only get into the buffer if
they
if we evaluate the agent on them first
compute its regret and if the regret is
higher than some threshold that's how we
curate the buffer
and that's it
um that's the entire algorithm
so they have a bunch of experiments
right here and
that's it's probably better to go back
to the website to look at the
experiments so
oh no we need to look at what the regret
is obviously
so regret is just a the way it's
formulated right here uh the regret is
the difference between the expected
rewards of two policy
so if i have a
this here is regret so the regret of
theta and now you know theta is a level
right so the regret uh specific to a
level
would be and here is policy one and
policy two now in this case it's the
current policy and the optimal policy
but you can see down here the regret can
be defined over any two arbitrary
policies
it is simply the difference
in the values of the two policies and
what's the value the value is the
expected future reward
and if i pose it like this it's probably
just the expected reward
so
the formulation right here
where i plug in the optimal policy
would simply be
you know what
um
i have some sort of level right and i
have my current agent right here and the
agent expects to get some sort of reward
like maybe it gets onto here and then it
crashes so that's a reward of i don't
know 50. and the optimal policy if the
level is solvable at all could actually
go to the end and solve it and get a
reward of 100 so my regret in this case
would be 50.
and that is
a good measure of how difficult the
level is or let's say how much you can
still learn from that level because if a
level is too difficult and that's the
catch if a level is too difficult then
not even the optimal policy will be able
to achieve much in that level and
therefore you know why are you like what
point is it to go to that level and
actually
um solve it or if there is any
stochasticity if if a level needs a lot
of luck
right then as well uh the expected the
expected reward the expected future
reward of the optimal policy will also
be not super high
so by selecting things that have high
regret meaning that have a high
difference between the optimal policy
and the current policy we select for
levels that
where the current student can still
learn
a lot of things
so it's still there's still head room to
learn
now the optimal policy is obviously hard
to compute because if we had it we
wouldn't have to solve the problem
so um
that there is a
an approximation we need to do because
we don't have access to the optimal
policy and the approximation is this
thing right here which is called the
positive value loss this is from
previous work by the way this this work
is essentially a combination of two
previous works this uh this plr i don't
it's okay i don't remember exactly right
now what it stands for but what plr does
is it also uses this regret objective
but it simply applies it to randomly
generated levels so it randomly
generates and it just curates that
random around those randomly generated
levels and the other thing that it
borrows from is evolutionary methods
which
maintain the evolutionary methods always
maintain a population and they do this
sort of editing the population and then
evaluating their fitness however most of
the evolutionary methods they are have
very hand tailored things of what it
means to be fit so the fitness function
could be quite uh quite
specific to a given environment and
remember we're not
we're not evolving the um
the agents here which of which fitness
would obviously just be like how well
can you solve a level uh we're evolving
the levels themselves
so the idea of this paper right here is
to simply use the regret
and
as a fitness function and then curate
the levels according to the according to
the regret
so it brings in evolution into the plr
algorithm with regret being the fitness
that's
i guess formulated in two different ways
so the positive value loss let's unpack
that real quick um
it stems from this thing right here
delta k delta k is the
td error at time step t so if i'm in a
level
and i'm at some time
time
these are the time steps and the
observations that i make through the
time steps the td error is i can compute
after i've completed the episode so at
each step i've gotten some sort of
reward maybe my reward here is r1 my
reward here is r2 r3
r4 and so on
uh so
in temporal difference learning
what i do is i always at each point in
time let's say i'm here
i want to estimate my future reward that
i'm going to make and that would be my
value function right so my value
function tells me what the future reward
will hold now i can estimate the reward
one step into the future or two steps
into the future or three steps and so on
my temporal difference error is simply
and i'm if it's written like this i
think that's
uh i'm not entirely sure if that's like
a td lumped or a td1 error
but in general
what i can do is i can just predict all
of my future rewards
and
the
difference between what i predict my
future awards to be and what they
actually are which i know after i've
completed the episode that's my td error
that's my temporal difference error i
can use the temporal difference error to
learn
a value function
because otherwise i'd have to learn the
value function just from the rewards
that i get
and the td error is a bit more of a
smooth
objective and i believe it converges to
the same thing ultimately
but you can reduce the variance a little
bit under certain assumptions
the
td error that we're interested in right
here it doesn't matter if we if the
agent uses it to learn or not but the
agent simply predicts the future rewards
along the way as it solves the level
after the level is completed we compare
that to the actual rewards that it got
we calculate the difference of that and
that becomes the td error then we sum up
the td error across from each time step
i can calculate a td error right
so i can do that from each time step if
i'm at time step t
i can
look ahead
okay yeah i can look ahead from each
time step until the end
and probably possibly the the td error
could be
looking from
from
either from or to that particular time
step
that is not exactly specified i would
have to go and read this paper
possibly
or the plr paper
it's not super important
we can add that up here are some
discount factors that we use for that
but you can disregard these for now
essentially it simply means okay from
time step t on
you know how wrong am i about the future
and
what we're going to do is we're going to
apply a relu to that so essentially
we're going to cap it at zero which
means that um
i'm only going to be interested in
wherever i
under or overestimate now let's think
about this
wherever i overestimate so the td error
as far as i know
is
the value minus the reward correct me if
that's a different way around
but it's what i estimate minus what it
truly is
now if this is high it means that i
completely overestimated my ability to
achieve reward in this level and that
could be you know a good level to train
on if i underestimated my ability to
achieve reward then i'm i'm gonna guess
that that level might be easier
than i had anticipated
so but if i overestimated that level
might be harder than i anticipated and
that's exactly the levels that i want to
train at
so
i'm going to cap that at zero i'm going
to sum that up across all the time steps
and if this number is very high it means
that throughout the level i consistently
overestimated my ability to make
progress in this level to get reward and
therefore that level should go into the
buffer so this is the approximation to
regret that we're going to use right
here and now you have the entire
algorithm
okay
generate levels give them to the student
evaluate them evaluate this measure does
the student under or overestimate its
ability if it overestimates the ability
put it into the buffer
then take stuff from the buffer
train the student on it give it to the
editor modify it
and evaluate the student again on it if
the student overestimates its ability on
the edited levels put them back into the
buffer and train on them
that's it you can also see a little bit
why this doesn't necessarily suggest
levels that are
way too hard because if you had a level
that was way too hard
the student might even correctly
estimate that it's not going to
make a lot of
a lot of progress there because it's
pretty easy to recognize that you're not
going to make a lot of progress uh if
the level is super duper hard right so
the levels that this is going to select
again is exactly the levels where
the student student thinks it should do
well but it doesn't really do well
so let's look a bit into the experiments
the experiments as i said are best
probably viewed on this website because
they're a bit interactive so what they
first do is they come up with these lava
grid levels and has the website crashed
again
so the lava oh no these are
the lava grid levels
they're procedurally generated the agent
must get to the goal while avoiding the
lava grids and
as the experiments show these get
progressively harder and harder
they next go to these mazes and excel
starts from just empty rooms so they
start from empty rooms and
up here i believe you can see some of
the generated levels by this algorithm
and the website has indeed crashed let's
refresh
so if we look at
what levels it generates you can see
that
the levels are
they're fairly difficult right but
they're also kinda random they don't
really look like human levels um so you
might be a bit doubtful of whether
that's gonna help in mazes that we
typically know
but you can clearly see the progress
from the initially empty rooms to it
filling up into actually becoming harder
and harder and harder
and if you then evaluate these things on
levels that humans have designed so
there's this benchmark right here it
will do pretty well especially against
these other methods
that also do curriculum evolution of of
levels
so especially things here like
large corridors so these are very
difficult
the agent only gets a little window
around itself to view it doesn't get an
overview over the entire um
over the entire level and therefore it
needs to sort of keep in mind things
that it did previously and that is a
hard task
and
they even this is really cool what they
do is they they have the agent to
generalize i believe from 16 by 16 grids
which they train on to
this 51 by 51 grid and you can see that
the agent it kind of follows it goes
like left hand always left
um and that works because
this maze does has no loops
um at least i believe it has no loops so
it in the end it actually finds the goal
uh why this is exactly 51 by 51 i don't
know maybe because the inside then is 50
by 50 or because that was just the
largest maze that it worked on but it is
astounding that it can sort of
generalize to
much much larger
things
because
in the small mazes it is conceivable
that it could kind of keep all of its
all of its history and memory but here
you can really see that it has learned
to develop an actual algorithm for what
it does right so there is an algorithm
like always go left
yeah
it's pretty uh i could you know could
watch forever um then they go on to to
these terrains and again
uh the thing here is that
without
hand crafting fitness functions or
anything like this just purely based on
these regret measures uh this these
levels they continuously evolve which
you can see right here
in what directions the levels evolve so
first
steps
are increased then stair heights and so
on
and at the end you'll have a generally
capable agent
they
they compare this um so they do some
ablations but interestingly sorry
they compare this to
poet and poet is an interesting
algorithm because poet trains a
population of agents so poet will always
pair environments and agents and try to
get the best achieving population of
agents which leads to very specialized
agents for very specialized types of
environments so the comparison is not
exactly accurate
but they do i believe they do show that
their algorithm takes a lot less
interactions obviously because it's only
one student and poet has an entire
population of students
and they also analyze over the course of
training
how their levels would fall into poets
because poet has a categorization of
levels of which ones are easy and hard
and so on
and as you can see right here it starts
off with a lot of easy levels on the
left and quite a bit of challenging
levels but not very many very
challenging or extremely challenging
levels and as time progresses you can
see that at least a little bit the
proportion of easy levels it sort of
takes a back seat and then the
proportion of extremely challenging
levels increases what is also
interesting at least for me is that um
it there's not a monotone monotonic
development into the direction of
challenging levels and that is what you
know i believe maybe this might be a
little bit of a sign of of this
catastrophic forgetting
because this is only a single agent
essentially if you train it into one
direction it might forget the other
directions that exist and specifically
it might you might forget how to do easy
levels because there's always a hill in
the challenging levels it might fall
over once it just encounters a flat
plane i've actually seen this a bunch of
times in
in the the trial runs that i did on the
website so it's pretty interesting to
see that even though
extremely challenging levels get added
and there's certainly more very
challenging level than at the beginning
and and less easy levels
it it does not converge to only having
extremely challenging levels
so that is also interesting here you can
see a little bit of a comparison notably
the top row a poet is a population-based
algorithm
as you can see here which is what makes
it different here are not super duper
comparable
then the other ones are so the plr as
you can see it also uses the minimax
regret strategy to curate levels however
there is no
it simply relies on random sampling from
the generator whereas excel uses the
random sampling plus evolution which
essentially means that it pairs the plr
algorithm algorithm with the poet
algorithm
and that appears to work quite well
so that is all that i wanted to say on
this work there's a lot more to say but
i hope that is is being clarified in the
interview with the authors what is a bit
a bit worrisome to me about this paper
is just the fact that
while they frame it
as oh this is very general this needs
essentially no heuristics and so on
i believe that is not entirely the case
i believe there's a lot of domain
knowledge that kind of gets sneaked in
side for example we need the this um we
need this threshold right on we need to
threshold
on the regret
so
there's a threshold only if it hits the
threshold we put it into the buffer like
they criticize poet for
filtering
levels where the agent gets between 50
and 300 reward and they kind of say well
that's kind of really
you know arbitrary and is really made
for that level and i agree
but then there is kind of a regret
threshold which um
is again that is kind of a hyper
parameter that i'm gonna guess that you
have to tune
and the same thing goes for you know how
do i edit these levels and so on i
believe them that it can be an arbitrary
editor but
again this is uh
it's it's very specific and i believe
what is most specific here is just the
choice of um the choice of tasks that
you go about
not every task and i would argue that
few very few tasks are actually
lend themselves to this kind of
evolution because again you need a very
you need to be able to create a very
smooth trajectory from
easy to hard where
the same or similar strategies
will solve all the different
difficulties and
in addition you need also to
to
be able for the editor
to edit levels in such a way that such a
path can be created right and
you need to avoid the catastrophic
forgetting you can't evolve into too
many different things at the same time
and so on
but i do think it's a cool method
and there's certainly certainly
applications and curriculum learning i
think is one of the most interesting
things that we can currently do uh
because
uh gone are the days of
like you essentially shift some
responsibility from the agent algorithm
to the environment creation algorithm
which i like right because we've seen
we've seen scaling up of agents
dramatically drastically and
maybe we can end up with a leaner agent
if we shift some of that learning
difficulty to the environment all right
that's what i had to say thank you very
much for listening bye
[Music]
you